he's now to begay he is uh working with
nbc sports
and golf channel analyst who joins us
from tpc
harding park and being a stanford alum
i'm sure that noda is uh quite familiar
with harding park
one of my favorite i love that whole
area there noda where
san francisco golf club might be my
second or third favorite golf
club uh course that i've ever played you
got olympic and then you got harding
park
that is a public course uh what stands
out the most at harding park to you
well right now in terms of how it's
prepared dan and great to be with you
again thanks for having me
is the fact that uh it it set up
championship
uh style to really test and bring out
the best in these players you know we
talk about this whole distance
issue with bryce and chambeau and just
how long the players have got tony fenow
but
this golf course the way it's set up and
i walked out there yesterday um
you know there are some tight driving
holes and if you hit it in the rough
it's a hit or miss whether or not you
get a good lie and have a chance to even
make a play for the green so it's going
to be a balanced test for the guys and i
mean they played in
90 plus degree heat you know 100
humidity last week it's 55 degrees and
the ball's going nowhere so
um you or i would not want to be out
there right now but these guys are
forced to be out there it's going to be
interesting to see how it turns out
if i said you could play in 50 degrees
or 100 degrees
what would you pick a hundred a hundred
a hundred out of a hundred times
just because the ball is going to go
further well
i mean it was a sore back that took me
out of golf
so any time it gets cold i get locked up
and i lose about
20 to 25 yards off the tee and um it's
no fun to play golf when you hit it
nowhere dan you know what i'm talking
about
i don't hit it anywhere and i think you
know deshambo is practicing social
distancing with his drives to everybody
else's
is this a bigger jump than when when
tiger
first came out and he was out driving
everybody is do shambo out driving
people the way tiger did when he first
came on tour
well it was really remarkable if you
want to make a comparative analysis in
terms of across all sports so
tiger was always long tiger was long as
a junior tiger was long
one of the longest in college and was
one of the longest when he came out on
tour
but what bryson has done is he wasn't
one of the longer players when he
joined the pga tour and what he's done
with his approach um is remarkable it's
like a major league
pitcher that gets drafted goes in into
you know gets onto a major league roster
and shows up with a 92 mile an hour
fastball
and then three or four years later it's
throwing a hundred
that that's that's really the the
comparison it just doesn't happen
and what he's been able to do and what's
what's most interesting about it
he's been able to do it without hurting
himself and he seems like he's on a
sustainable track
um you know you'd have to talk to
trainers to see how sustainable
maintaining that much new muscle mass is
but uh he's done it really well and he's
kind of
found the holy grail of golf which is 20
yards of extra distance off the tee
how are we not suspicious about that
because if it was a pitcher who went
from 92 to 100 nota
we would go hmm but in golf
we don't always add that question mark
at the end of somebody when we see a
different physique
like brooks kepca i don't think that
when i see him
but if he was in another sport we might
go hmm
he's consistent nota you know bryson is
i mean this is pretty crazy the size and
the distance that he's created here
yeah that's a great point and i think
the only thing that i could sort of fall
back on is the fact that the pj tours
testing program in terms of performance
enhancing drugs and all that
has progressed and it's at at the same
level as any other major uh sports in
america
i mean it's not new we've been doing it
now for a decade and
it's just one of those things where
these guys are getting routinely tested
not only
are they getting swabs shoved up their
nose every week uh to test for covid but
uh they're getting regular uh urine
samples and all of that stuff to make
sure that there's nothing crazy going on
so
um i just you know all that aside i got
to give him credit for
doing doing what he's done and and
making it work for him
he's not to be gay nbc sports golf
channel analyst
tiger changing his putter noda
you've you've seen that putter as long
as you've probably known
tiger he you're royal you love your
putter
and all of a sudden he's changing how
surprising well uh he's not the only one
i think we all love that putter just for
all of the the memories and the great
moments it's given us over the last 30
years
and i've hit putts with that putter and
i've seen a whole
shelf of about 50 different attempts to
replicate that putter and i asked him
one day we're in his house and he has
a big wall with all the clubs that have
been made for him over the years and
i go not one of those 50 putters on the
wall was even close he goes no
he goes it just it just wasn't the right
feel
and you know i'm who am i to question
the greatest golfer ever
in the sense of what he's feeling as the
as the ball sits on the face and comes
off with
the truest role that we've ever seen but
you know he struggled you look back you
go back to genesis he had
four three putts and and a four putt so
he gave up six shots to the field and
finished
they finished last um that particular
week
and then he comes back to memorial and
missed a series of short putts and
struggled a little bit so
he's like anybody else he's just out
here trying to find something that
can give him a little bit of hope that
he can
he can hold a few extra putts because
we've seen that his t degree game is
is pretty solid when uh he's in good
form and i think he's
um he's looking good this week in this
practice round
yeah but it's weird he's got a putting
coach right
i a putting advisor
but but i i don't know it feels like
steph curry probably doesn't have a
shooting coach
but like tiger is the greatest you can
make the case greatest golfer of all
time but
i guess is some of that just a security
blanket that you sort of want somebody
there
i mean do you really need somebody there
for i i strongly feel no i think that
um you're better off in a lot of cases
using people that have been around you
he's got a great friend and rob mcnamara
who has known him since junior golf
he's got a wonderful caddy and joy
lacava i think those are guys that would
give you a better sense of where your
setup is because
golf is so technical you're talking
about a quarter of a degree
closed or shut at impact the ball is
going to spray 10 to 15 yards left or
right to your target and
you can't get the ball started online
when you're putting
there's really no way you can match up
your read with your speed if you're not
squaring up the face at impact so
any little adjustments and we've seen it
throughout the years we've seen
players put new putters in their bag
that particular week and go out and win
it's just one of those things where you
match up the mechanical motion
and the the setup of the equipment to
the player's mentality and it just
creates magic
you know who i'd go to me
no i'm a great fighting coach dan no
steve stricker
yes and steve's been an advisor for for
tiger through the years
they've partnered quite a few times in
the president's cup
and uh the ryder cup and you know he
will rely on steve from time to time to
give him a little bit of feedback and
where tiger really struggles a little
bit with his setup is just his left hand
it gets a little little off and
sometimes he just needs to readjust
where his left hand sits to get the club
on pass
how many times did you beat tiger in
college
uh quite a few and over the years it's
gotten more and more
but um the older you get
the better you were noticed absolutely
i carried
he showed up on the farm uh you know i
put my arms around him and i gave him
the charles barkley talk and i said hey
you're going to be the strongest
freshman in america
and he goes great tried to stay humble
and i go well it's because you're going
to carry all the seniors we had four
seniors and a freshman you're going to
carry all our bags on our trip
also you hazed him oh absolutely it was
a great sport about it
and finally casey martin myself were the
co-captains of the team and
he came into the hotel room one night
says hey if i go out and i win a
tournament
can i stop carrying these bags you know
this is kind of old you know
you know i'm a tiger woods and
we go sure sure because you know he
wasn't playing great at the time and uh
he he he went out and won the next week
which kind of sucked for us
we didn't get to give him our bags yeah
i've i've mentioned this before on the
show i have a nephew who
used to sell products and deliver he
would go to reservations
in north dakota and he would come back
and he would say i know you talk about
hey the washington redskins
people on these reservations don't care
about that nickname
they want running water they want people
to help out with
alcoholism and addiction and they want
you know they want normal things in
their lives
is that like your opinion of what's
going on with the washington football
team
how much does it matter to you one way
or another nota if they're
whatever they're called it it's a it's a
huge
it has a huge negative impact um
on the perception that native american
people have about themselves and
and i agree there's a lot of people in
my community that have sort of
wondered you know what why is this why
is this an issue and
i tell them it's an issue because of
someone like me who came from the
reservations and
um always felt slighted in a lot of
situations you walking for
into a job interview you walk into um
one of these you know very uh
prestigious golf clubs and
um you know there's a different feel and
we're we're trying to break down those
stereotypes we're trying to break down
those misconceptions about who we are as
native american people and
uh we certainly don't want to be mocked
and we don't want to be
held to a lower standard and i think you
know for my children and for many of
my my friends that that razor kids on
reservations
uh this is a good step because they can
look up and see that there are people
out there that are advocating
for a better um perception
of who we are as people and to be a
little bit more respectful of everybody
across the board i think
in this whole mission to produce a more
equal viewpoint amongst all americans uh
it's important to
to include all americans and i know you
started a foundation because i was
thinking about you that covet has really
ravaged
some of these reservations here and
i think you've said publicly that you
might lose family members
because of covet yeah i have lost
extended family people that
i see at christmas gatherings and
thanksgiving meals
uh are gone uh one of a
really very close friend of mine on the
navajo nation who i grew up playing
youth basketball who
grew up across the street from me in
windark arizona
uh his grandma and my grandma lived
across the street from each other
both he and his brother he's my age he
and his younger brother died on the same
day from cover 19. so it's hit very
close to home and
it just kind of highlights the lack of
infrastructure
in our communities across the board
whether it's healthcare whether it's
first responders
um and the ability to respond to this
this sort of sort of health crisis uh
it's impacting the death rate amongst
native american communities is 20 times
the national
average and um it's just it's it's a
tough place and we've got
a long uphill climb and i don't want
people to forget about us
as we continue to try and lift ourselves
back up because we we are proud people
we're capable um it's just sometimes you
you're up against something that's a
little bit tough to overcome
nb3 is the foundation it's a coven 19
response fund for native americans
and uh also he's creating the notable
gay
junior golf national championship as
well
live from the pga championship it's
must-see on golf channel
the winner of the pga championship will
be
who brooke's going oh wow i didn't even
get to finish
yeah sorry there was a lag there in my
signal but yeah i
i was already answering you before you
got out of it
i mean that's how we're connected dan
you know i'm finishing your sentence
wow wow we're like a couple now i i like
that
so brooks kept if i gave you brooks
kepca or the field
i take brooks in a heartbeat i just wow
he's trending he's edgy and
you know he's going for there's some
cool things happening this week there's
brooks going for three consecutive pga
championships in a row there's
jordan spieth trying to pull himself out
of a slump but if he
if he's able to do it wins the career
grand slam um and then tiger woods going
obviously for number 16 major in his
career if it was
brooks kepca bryson deschambeau arm
wrestling
oh man arm wrestling i'd probably take
bryson right now
but in a wrestling match i might take
like
wwe style in a ring i'd take brooks
he's a lot meaner maybe we see that this
weekend it feels like brooks is
brooks is not afraid to tweak bryce into
shambo a little bit right there
hey he's not he's not and and there's an
idea for a podcast you know
pj tour players in the wrestling arena i
mean i may just submit my
my entry oh no in the octagon
yeah that'd be even better how would how
would tiger wouldn't do well in the
octagon he's got too many surgeries
right
uh yeah he's he's a little banged up
i think he'd do more running than
wrestling maybe 2005
ty have you ever seen tiger in a fight
dude
you know but he did he did get robbed in
a parking lot at stanford one night so
uh i don't think he fought the guy
because i think he got i mean it's a
serious thing he did actually did get
robbed
um at knifepoint which was an
unfortunate incident but
um uh he recovered nothing happened he
was good
and um he's gone on to do some pretty
good things
i still maintain 2 000 at pebble beach
is the greatest golf performance in the
sports history
oh by that whole year dan i mean we
won't ever see
any golf like that um ever again
i mean at least in our lifetime be just
the the run of quality
on those venues historic venues pebble
beach saint andrews and then he capped
it off with that
amazing win over bob may at valhalla
which was just something that
i was glad to be up i played in all
three of those events so i was
pretty lucky to be there how many
strokes did he beat you by in the u.s
open at pebble
oh we had to go there
he beat he beat second place by 15. oh i
know
i was i was well well well
i and knowing tiger he might remind you
of that
you know just if you bring up i beat you
in in college he would probably remind
you of a couple other things there he
could humble you quickly probably yeah
he humbles me but i i got a couple i got
there's two in my head pocket so in 1994
we won a
national championship at stanford as a
team without tiger
and then we replaced our worst player
our fifth man
with tiger woods and we had four
returning seniors the next day we were
the bonafide number one ranked team in
the country in 1995 and we lost in a
playoff we finished second
so i always hold over his head that he
made us the worst team when he arrived
at stanford and that i graduated with my
degree in economics
but he didn't graduate but then he
always comes back and at the time but
now it's different he used to say he has
four masters
but now he has five so his master's
degree
uh his master's degree hey it's great to
talk to you and uh have fun this week
we'll be watching uh
the uh the gulf there thank thank you
again always appreciate
thank you buddy thanks for having me
that is uh no to be gay